hey Amy good morning Amy good morning
Amy it is 5:00 a.m.
um getting ready getting ready to go to
last Jedi last trip oh boy everybody
it's stove time all right so right off
the bat um bottom line I'll lead with
the bottom line on on this one if if you
don't like the force awakens you
probably won't like the last Jedi
because liking the last Jedi is largely
predicated on liking the characters and
if you don't like the characters if you
don't like how they've been set up if
you don't like where they're going if
you don't like how they're being
portrayed how they just hey've
everything about him if you don't like
the characters from The Force awakens
then you are probably this probably
isn't going to change your mind however
if you do like the characters if you
like the kind of adventures they get up
to if you like their their dynamic with
each other
then you are in for a ride I liked this
movie I liked this movie a lot it made
me feel feelings in ways that that it
has been a while since a movie impacted
me in in ways that this one managed to
and I'll get into those later but that
right there there's the bottom line I I
really enjoyed the movie I think it did
a lot of great things I enjoyed the
force awakens and this is a continuation
of that and thus I I am I am along for
the ride I like these characters I like
where they're going I am enjoying how
their story is unfolding I am enjoying
the ongoing drama of Rey and Po and Finn
and
all of them so so there's kind of
there's my bottom line now from here on
out I'm going into my normal sort of
style which if you're not familiar with
it my normal style it's going to be wide
open we're going to be talking about
spoilers this is more of a this this is
not so much a review as it is a debrief
if you haven't seen the movie and you
want to and you don't want it this is
you know don't don't go go watch it then
come back and we will discuss it
together so from here on out it's it's
not the spoiler zone you're in the pork
zone so off the top of my head first
thing I continue to find kylo Ren to be
a very compelling antagonist I think
they've done a really good job of
writing the character I think Adam
driver continues to do a really good job
of bringing him to life I'm just I'm I'm
enjoying this villain that that is
basically just a rage driven insecure
manchild I think that fits very well
into the the narrative arc of Star Wars
I think it fits very well into the you
know the the the metaphysical conflict
at the heart of the stories universe and
it creates a villain that's that's fun
and interesting and believable in a way
that you know that that he makes
mistakes but rather than being plot
holes those are actual character
mistakes they are miss judgments that
are made by a character who has very
understandable motivations and you know
it allows you to set up set up dynamics
it allows you to set up scenes it allows
you to create conflicts in both
directions because this there's a great
great moment in the middle of the film
at the whole the whole scene with Rey
and kylo Ren in snoke's throne room it
is just this fantastically well staged
moment and the
the conflict of the scene the the
emotional energy of the scene hinges
around the fact that kylo Ren is driven
largely by insecurity and that
insecurity flows both ways that that Rey
sees it as basically the opportunity to
bring him back
that that that insecurity means that
there is still uncertainty there is
still a part of kylo Ren that wants to
be Ben solo that wants to be just a
normal happy person but it also flows
you know the other direction and it is a
source of rage and resentment and
anxiety and that stoke that Snoke that
Snoke gloating about using that weakness
in order to in order to basically toy
with Toby with rent and get him to do
things that Snoke wants him to do ends
up being Stokes downfall and just the
the evolution of that scene is that
unfolds gets even better because it's
like at it plays back and forth it's
like oh he's going to he's going to do
what Snoke wants but then he he doesn't
and he done you know he kills Snoke
instead and so the the tension jumps out
it's like oh well is he actually has he
been zou code is he going over to Ray's
side you know is this is the rest of
this going to be kylo Ren and Rey and
Finn and Poe against you know Huck's and
the first order like what's what's the
next sort of evolution of this and then
but then once the smoke clears once the
adrenaline wears off what was presented
as kylo Ren turning back to the light
side is actually just a coup as he you
know things clear and he's like way we
had
we now have this massive power vacuum
that is mine if I want it and he just
goes in goes in and grabs it and you
know has that moment of like hey ray you
and me we get each other we do
understand we have made a connection you
see you and me we're both the same we're
both garbage we should be working
together to just you know fix all of
this we have the power to fix everything
and you know it's it's it's a really
good moment it's a really good well
crafted moment that it's driven by some
some you know good character writing and
some great acting on on the part of the
performers with that I do want to say
like Daisy Ridley so I don't really have
any any complaints with her performance
in the force awakens but the the growth
as a performer between then and now is
visible she has she has grown a lot as a
performer her performance here in the
force in the last Jedi is a lot stronger
and and the movie is all the better for
it so like that that was really a really
good to see there's a moment that I
guess this is a bit of a small criticism
they so the movie as a whole gets really
focused on these kinds of character
moments and these specific character
motivations and that's good and is for
the most part a strength but there's one
scene in particular where it it kind of
goes a little bit too far and that's the
introduction of vice-admiral hold oh so
the scene is supposed to like it's it's
a bit of a laughs moment and you know it
does get a response from from the
audience like it does work as a laughs
moment I'm just not sure that it works
to the benefit of the movie as a whole
with how important vice-admiral whole
dough ends up being so on on script on
the page it makes sense as being you
know bottled in to pose sort of tunnel
vision point of view you
do that he there's his own sense of loss
his own sense of ego his own sense of
entitlement you know assuming that
naturally he's going to be the one who
is going to take command because he's
the person who's been there all along at
least visibly and in his mind visibly
yes he is the person who's been there
all along and then it turns out to be
you know Vice Admiral hold oh and so so
that's deflating moment when when they
bring whole dough in is is good and it
ends up being a good laugh moment for
the audience unfortunately just because
of how critical hold oh then ends up
being to the plot as a whole it's it's
kind of this unfortunate moments of
bringing this really important character
in it's just kind of like all right and
here's Jim who is very important and has
been here all along right over there
just off-camera the entire time
everybody welcome Jim
so so that's a little bit unfortunate I
think maybe it would have been better
for the the strength of the movie as a
whole if if whole dough had been
actually introduced on her own terms a
little bit earlier but I mean that it's
kind of a minor thing like it's like
okay well they're trying to really focus
on this character moment and that's good
and it does work as a laughs moment but
then it kind of undercuts a secondary
character a little bit and it's like
okay well you know where do you make
those trade-offs it's like no no script
is really going to nail it especially
not one with like this many characters
like you're gonna end up making a few
trade-offs like that and so it's it's
not the biggest complaint but it is
something that's there another thing
that unfortunately detracted from the
movie for me is it's hard to you can't
watch movies in a vacuum like it's just
literally impossible to watch movies in
in a true vacuum and so for a lot of the
movie this the the knowledge that I have
of you know Carrie Fisher
Dawei last fall and this is the second
of three movies so what are they going
to do with her character so that was
unfortunately a thing that was kind of
looming over me for the for the entire
movie and there's the moment early on
where she she almost dies and then
spends much of the movie in critical
condition it you know it's kind of this
like oh is this how they're gonna handle
it is this how they're going to write
her out is you know and then when she
gets better it's kind of it continues to
loom over the rest of the movie like
alright is she gonna die are they just
gonna write her out how how are they
going to deal with the death of the
actress because she can't be in the next
movie and I guess they've decided
they'll cross that bridge when they come
to it that they didn't go back and like
restructure the ending of the ending of
the film after her passing they just
they went ahead all all as planned and I
don't know we'll see we'll see how it
goes when when the next movie comes out
we'll see how they they deal with that I
guess another another minor minor issue
the detour to the casino planet is
something that feels kind of uneven so
like the the drama on the casino planet
and the drama back with the fleet are
are both appropriate within themselves
but having them run in parallel as
linked as they are doesn't it's it's a
little uneven it takes a bit to kind of
like sink into it especially since they
they spend so much time leading up to
that departure leading up to the split
ramping up the Jeopardy on the fleet
side of things you know they they just
keep ratcheting up the stakes there and
then you know
rose and fin take off for the casino
planet and it's just the the timescale
of those two scenarios really don't line
up and it takes a bit to kind of sink
into it and it's even to the point that
after they leave what by the time it
like they get to the casino planet and
it's it's when they're there that they
kind of back up and go oh actually the
fleet can continue this slow-motion
chase for like 16 more hours like no no
we've got we've got time it's like it's
like we're basically out of time and
we've got no fuel left but we've got
enough fuel left to kind of actually
keep going for like the rest of the day
in a bit and so that was kind of it's
like it took a bit to kind of kind of
sync those up but you know not a huge
not a huge issue next on my notes so I
have this note here I've got this note
here that just says ramming the ship at
light speed so the this moment holy crap
so one of the downsides of the
proliferation of CG heavy big-budget
action blockbusters is that they all
have started to sort of look and feel
the same because the action stuff is all
out of made out of the same material
it's all made out of just you know
computer imagery and it all it has the
same texture it has the same feel and
people are hitting the same beats I mean
we've already started to joke about how
every superhero is ultimately just
battling a giant beam of light shooting
up into the sky you know that the the
imagery and the sound design and the
color palette has all gotten very samey
and so to have this moment in
this movie that was just legitimately
breathtakingly beautiful from the the
just micro timing of how it unfolds to
the sound design to the visuals of it
like it it took my breath away and it
has been years since a just action set
piece in a movie has been that
impressive to me and so that was that
was a wild moment holy crap
like literally held my breath and and
had to just exhale once once kind of the
tension released so so congratulations
to just everybody involved in in
bringing that cinematic morsel to life
yeah
as a general rule though like in in this
movie like as a general rule like all of
the action set-pieces almost all of them
like were were tense I found myself
engaged in them I found myself invested
in the stakes I understood the stakes
the the Jeopardy was clear the character
in the jeopardy was clear you know and
they they managed to use action to tell
story not just plot but character story
very well posed arc in this his
character moments in this are very much
rooted in the action scenes and in fact
his behavior in the action scenes is in
fact is what kind of gets him into into
hot water in the first place that ends
up leading to him growing a little as as
a character and then that ends up
rolling over onto onto some other
characters so I think that's really
really just well-crafted drama drama
action and adventure there so that's
good that's I really liked
that stuff there's some comedy that I
suspect people are going to criticize
like I can I can I can see it coming I
can feel it
that people are going to complain that a
lot of the comedy is too silly in
particular like the opening where PO is
dunking on Hux and I'm gonna say no I I
like it I love it I love watching Hawks
get dunked on by absolutely everyone
because here's the thing Huck's is a
space not see he is inherently absurd he
is inherently stupid and he does not
deserve to be treated with dignity and
respect I have an entire video on on the
visual propaganda of Nazis and how it
has infected our language that we use
like the visual language that we use to
sort of deal with these sort of subjects
and so I am I am glad to see a I like
seeing a movie that uses 90% of the
visual language of Nazis and then just
treats them like crap like doesn't treat
them as as you know scary dangerous in
control but dunks on them and doesn't
doesn't respect them so I am happy that
Hux gets dunked on by everyone
he does not deserve dignity or respect
there there's a really silly line so so
the final the final planet is the salt
planet of cran and the problem with a
salt planet is a salt planet looks more
or less identical to a snow planet and
there's even a there's a bunch of
animals that you see in the in the
trailer and you see you know that you
see running into into a cave and they're
all made of crystals but they also look
like they're made of
because Isis ice is crystals so how do
you how do you communicate to the
audience that this isn't snow this is
salt well you have a character basically
lick the ground and say uh uh salt it
was it was it was a little it was I I
felt that one a little too much as a
screenwriting fix like that it's like
okay we need we have a problem we need
to solve it screw it let's just have
somebody saying got a laugh from the
audience though they people liked it so
alright alright we'll take it we'll take
it okay so a hanging a hanging bit of
drama from the previous movie is raised
parentage now this is actually an
interesting one because I was mentioning
this after after the force awakens came
out you know this like okay there's kind
of this this mystery of raised parentage
is is clearly kind of set up and left
hanging as you know important
information is this kind of like magical
box that we're going to have to peer
into in the future and weirdly a bunch
of people were like what no I didn't
what no what that's it's not it's it's
not a mystery I'm like what he what are
you talking about and so I felt a little
bit vindicated when this movie like
explicitly centers it as a mystery but
then the answer to that mystery I loved
just as much because so I was
hypothesizing back when back when it
came out they're just like okay the
answer to this mystery is gonna be one
of two things either they're going to
jump through some absurd hoops to you
know tie her into the great space
families in some way like she's gonna be
a long-lost Kenobi or she's gonna be you
know she's she's there they're gonna
introduce Mara Jade and you know Luke
had a tryst with her and Luke has a
secret daughter and even though the
timelines don't really match up or
anything but like whatever like just
it's thing moving on like that it was
going to be something on that side
or it was gonna be nobody it wasn't
going to be just another like here's Jim
moment here's Jim he's very important
he's been hanging out just off-screen
this whole time it wasn't gonna be a
moment like that that they were going to
go explicitly nobody and that's the
decision that they made and I'm glad
they went with it both because it
vindicates my own my own preference in
the solution to that to that mystery but
because it tells a better story and it
it makes a change to Star Wars that I
think is kind of sorely needed Star Wars
has a bit of this long-running flaw
where it is always about this same like
dozen people and not just in a like
story perspective like oh well of course
it focuses on the same like dozen people
it's about them but the galaxy the
literal fate of the galaxy consistently
repeatedly revolves around this small
cluster of people and you know their
immediate environs it's not that other
things are happening around them is this
like no they are the pivot point for
everyone and so I thought it was it's
it's a really good sort of response to
that - then have Ray come in and it's
like oh well what's how does she tie
into that pivot point and it's like well
she kind of doesn't she she only she
ties into it because she gets to know
them she falls a little bit into their
gravity well but she is not she's not a
long-lost Kenobi she's not a long-lost
Skywalker she's the kid of some junk
farmers it's a disappointing answer but
it's an explicitly disappointing answer
it's not just it's not a disappointing
story answer it's a disappointing
character answer it is intentionally
unfulfilled and that's the point of it
the point of it is that it's
not a happy fulfilling complicated rich
answer it's it's just a little empty and
it's a little sad and it's you know but
that's the emotion that it's a meant to
evoke is that you know you you go into
it it's like well not everything is
fulfilling some things just are
disappointing and disappointment is a
tricky emotion for movies and video
games and television it's a tricky
emotion to to play with because it is a
very very fine line to walk between
something that evokes disappointment as
a conscious emotion and something that's
just unfulfilled as a story beat so I
think they managed to thread that needle
really well I really enjoyed how they
unfolded in this of course goes back to
like Daisy Ridley's visible growth as a
performer that she really sells it an
atom driver who plays off of her in the
scene like he he sells it as well like
just the two of them working back and
forth with that with that beat is is
really really good character moment
there and you know communicates that
disappointment not just as character
motivation but also you know a bigger
sort of metaphorical moment for you know
a theme moment for the for the audience
to grasp onto one of the other kind of
the I guess the last thing here that
I'll sort of wrap up with I really
appreciate a lot of the small details so
back in the original Star Wars there was
there's a cutscene there's a a scene
that was that was cut from the film
where during the space battle over over
Tatooine at the at the beginning of the
film it actually goes down to Luke's
perspective as he's like making the
rounds out on the farm and he looks up
and he sees the battle from from down on
the planet he sees it up in the sky and
that scene for for pacing reasons and a
couple others it was it was cut from cut
from the film so I'm I'm glad to see
that you know both the force awakens
rogue one and the last Jedi have have
used that planets I perspective that
like looking up into space and seeing
you know seeing the Death Star seeing
[Music]
the Star Destroyer seeing like ships you
know jumping in and out of Lightspeed
from from the planets I perceive it's
it's a great little detail that that
does just a fantastic job of evoke in
that sense of like Wonder in that sense
of fantasy and adventure that it's like
okay you are in a fantastic place now
and we are going to go on a fantastic
adventure and we are going to see things
that you could not see in in your
day-to-day life we're going to explore
fantasy and I just I really like those
moments I think they're they're used
sparingly in the films in there but
they're used very well to to set a scene
two sets you into the world and so I
really I really like that I really like
the small that small detail and it also
I mean it does play off the fact that
like okay we know what a Star Destroyer
is and so if you're down on a planet and
you see three Star Destroyers warp in to
orbit it's like oh crap we know what
that means as an audience and so it
instantly sets the tension for for the
moment it's like there okay there's the
stakes there's the threat there's the
jeopardy let's go let's let's grab our
stuff and go on an adventure and so I I
really I really liked this movie there's
a lot more that I could talk about that
I is probably slipping my mind but
yeah yeah I I liked it so what did you
think doesn't matter I liked it hectic
wants I don't care if you hated this
movie I really don't I really don't it
made me happy it made me happy
hey Amy Amy Amy you kind of look like a
pork you kind of look like a poor gamey
see you even have bitey teeth you even
have bikie teeth like a pork workzone
[Music]